hey ji D or my real name
I was playing which go home my
grandmother gave me the name when I was
a baby I was reactive and always moving
so she says jittery like with a D this
sounds like a D so I just cut it down
the ji d she doesn't actually remember
giving me the name
last time acts she's just like but
what's up everybody it's the kids ji d
I'm here at GQ and I'm gonna show you
some of my tattoos tell my first tattoo
when I was 13 on my stomach I remember
on seeing my brother he had a tat and I
was like hey I wanna I want to be like
Dennis stuff I seen all my brothers at
test and I'm like the youngest
so how 13 my last name is root so it's
like root boy and it's like flames
hello childish I start shooting from the
hip cuz I got him early so so did you
get a test when we 13 we in middle
school like I'm the coolest guy now you
know I'm saying walk around my shirt up
all day like yo I'm gonna keep him to
came to school they didn't know what I
was hiding them from you know I'm saying
so I never want my shirt off around my
parents for like ages 13s like 18
dancers I had on like a cut-off shirt so
one day she lifted me sure she looked
again you said come back she put into
his I think you got a tattoo she wasn't
really upset as I thought she would
because I was about to go to like
college I was leaving the house or the
name of that thing I like more than 40
tattoos
I'm like the poster child for like the
people who got tats before they had like
a full-functioning mind and now I'm like
looking myself like I should await it
and I could have did something really
great back kind of like a little ugly
clown over here some flames that's real
we I'm gonna get it all fixed up and
then over here I got like a naked alien
pointing over a cliff got like a lion
eating a gazelle just I'm just a nature
freak so I love this stuff
I like my favorite numbers I got a
picture of me too that drew it's kind of
meat right there this is really just a
skeleton it's not even that good of a
drama
if I had to choose a favor it'll be this
angel on my neck I think it's on your
side it's the only one I know I was
reading like the Bible or some now my
damning read about when I was kid and I
noticed they say is no such thing as
like women angels it's like angels in
vows no they're not women
I like the unknown I like trying to like
dig deeper into that type of stuff so
that's like something that I looked up
now and I hope I'm right about that but
there's something I looked up and I was
like oh all right it's like a piece you
know I'm saying a think piece kind of
and I explained it you seems like a
weird line right here it's like a weird
scar I got that one I don't know why I
did it it's probably a scar like
dripping blood
and so just little bittle I know that
I got a done in LA but it's doing the
exact he's pretty dope and I got these
Nightmare Before Christmas and my
birthday Halloween some obvious cool
I've never
my birthday's no Halloween I've never
worn one costume with my whole life I
let everybody else celebrate I just
enjoy myself I finished has like the
skin you know you replace your skin or
whatever so finger test go away so this
is like a noose on the inside it says
pain or whatever and then this one is
like a heart
but it's bleeding and got a nail through
it and then you said like struggling
inside of fingerprints going away and
then it's like a money sign yeah [ __ ]
money love you know it's really just
like a cross but it's like right right
but real casual whatever this part is
right here sucks really sucks really bad
[Music]
these over here is kind of cool all
right so I dislocated my hip right I was
on crutches the doctor said I won't play
football no more so I put laugh-out-loud
and a football this is like 17 year old
me our parents in this Lewis name are
here to say initials parents is in God
is how I got through that and then all
these of our brothers and sisters
initials and we often Georgia and all
that kept me focused I guess that was a
little dumb story that I was put
together and tells you I ain't it I
ain't do that in a minute either
when I started in Ted I went in you know
I'm saying so I feel like it was more
like of an influence thing you know I'm
saying me singing my friends I like all
we can tell you like we was the first
one said it but right now not really
forceful of because I've been did it you
know I'm saying I did it before it was
even cooler stuff I did I never planted
like Ted in my face I don't [ __ ] with
that I think I like my face
the tribes Africa they get little marks
little slices or whatever they are kind
of one is something like I kind of love
that that'd be super weird but I would
do that I would get just like one little
but it's not attack